welcome back well i'm now going to prove
to you that uh the centripetal or the
magnitude of centripetal acceleration is
equal to the magnitude of the velocity
of when you're going around a circle
divided of the velocity squared divided
by the radius so let's start with the
drawing just so that we know what we're
doing
just as much for me as it is for you
so that's the circle and as you can
guess that's going to be our path
and let's draw let's call p our position
vector
and let's see this is the center of the
circle right here
we do the position vector in magenta
so let's say that this is
p the our my position let me draw that
boulder let me do it here you go
so that's the vector p
that's the vector p
and let's say let me define a few other
things over here
so let's say that the angle that it's
forming
with the positive x-axis let's say this
is the positive x-axis
is
theta that that says theta right there
and let's say the radius of the circle
is r so we do we have a uh object it's
something it's right here this is its
position right defined by this position
vector and it's spinning around so it's
position vectors going to you know at
some point the r is going to be pointed
like there then like there is it's going
to go around and around a circle but
this is its position vector at some
moment in time
so let's let's what is that position
vector in our kind of uh what did i call
that our our bracket notation of vectors
well we have to figure out it's x and y
component so it's x component is right
here
you know or you could almost almost say
it's a
well
it's i component
if we were doing the engineering
notation that's its x component and
that's its y component
right
so in our bracket notation or whatever i
always forget what i call things
p
is
this
p which is our position vector
what's its x component it's the radius
times the cosine of theta this should be
second nature to you at this point
radius times cosine of theta
and what's its y component it's this
right it's just this that's its y
component it's radius
times the sine of theta
fair enough hopefully that makes sense
to you so far i just defined its
position vector and i uh
i drew it out here visually and then i
also wrote it analytically in in kind of
its x and y components as a sum of its x
and y components well that's good in
everything so let's see if we can figure
out what its velocity vector is
well what is velocity velocity is
actually just a change in position and
actually now we are actually dealing
with velocity not speed we will actually
get a vector so what is the velocity
vector so the velocity vector is going
to be you know at any given point in a
different color the velocity vector is
going to be tangent to the circle it's
going to look something like that
that's going to be the velocity vector
so the velocity vector
is equal to the change in the position
over time right
so let's take the derivative
of the position vector
with respect to time
and how do we take a derivative well we
could just take the derivative of the x
and y component separately and we'll
i'll show you how we do it in this
notation and if you think about it
should make a little bit of sense
so the radius is constant right as we go
around the circle the radius isn't
changing another thing to keep in mind
we're going around we're spinning around
the circle at a constant rate so my
speed isn't changing my velocity is
obviously changing because the direction
is changing but the actual
rate at which i'm spinning or the
angular velocity is going to be a
constant that's something to keep in
mind for
what we get to in the next step but
anyway let's take the derivative
so the derivative let's take the
derivative of the x term first
the x term
well r is just a constant right so it
doesn't change we can just take the r
out
and then what's the derivative of cosine
theta with respect to time not with
respect to theta remember we're taking
the derivative with respect to time
so we do the chain rule
it's the derivative of theta with
respect to time
so it's the derivative of theta with
respect to time
times the derivative
of cos of this term with respect to
theta and what's the derivative of this
well it's minus
sine of theta
times
let me put the minus out here minus
sine of theta i just didn't want to put
the minus right in front of the sine
because you would think it's a minus
sine theta so it's minus r times the
rate of change of the angle with respect
to time times sine of theta right the
rate at which this term is changing with
respect to theta let's do the same thing
on the y side r is a constant
chain rule
the rate at which theta is changing with
respect to time
theta with respect to time and then
what's the derivative of sine of theta
with respect to theta well that's cosine
of theta right this was just the co this
was just the chain rule that i did
so let's see if we can simplify that a
little bit
so
d theta dt in both of these that's the
same thing as angular velocity and watch
the video in angular velocity if that
doesn't make sense to you
but we can simplify this as just
w right angular velocity and that's
going to be a constant
and we have an r there so let's see we
have let's say let's take a w r out of
both sides so we have the velocity
vector
is equal to
this was an equal
the velocity vector is equal to
w r
actually let's take our minus wr out so
minus
wr
and then this term is sine of theta
sine of theta and we're taking a minus
wr so the wr goes when we introduce a
minus sign here so it's minus cosine of
theta
minus cosine of theta
good enough and the reason why we were
able to take and this w remember is
going to be a constant it's not changing
with respect to time the
the uh the angle is changing with
respect to time but not the rate of
change of the angle it's spinning at a
constant rate so what's the acceleration
vector going to be well the acceleration
vector and i'll switch colors again to
keep it interesting
the acceleration vector is just the
the derivative of the velocity vector
with respect to time so it's the
derivative of the velocity vector
with respect to time
and that equals we'll
take this this is this constant term so
let's leave it on the outside minus wr
and chain rule again
what's the if if we're taking the
derivative with respect to time first if
you take the derivative of theta with
respect to time and we don't know what
that it would that's just going to be w
d d
d theta d t and then times this
expression
the derivative of this respection with
this expression with respect to theta so
sine of theta derivative is cosine of
theta
and then on the y side
we have well what's the derivative of of
theta with respect to time well
that's just you know
that's going to just be omega
and then what's the derivative of minus
cosine theta with respect to theta well
that's sine theta
and once again
this is w
and this is w we can take the w out of
the equation and we get the acceleration
vector is equal to take the w out of the
x and y components is equal to
minus w squared r
times
cosine
theta
sine
theta
or we could take this r and multiply it
times both of these the x and y
components and we have the acceleration
vector is equal to minus w squared
r cosine theta
r sine
theta
now does this thing here look familiar
well sure that was our original position
vector
so we could say that the acceleration
vector
is equal to
minus our angular velocity squared times
the position vector
and that that makes actually a lot of
sense because well w square is going to
be a positive term and what so what it's
saying is going to be
the negative the direction of this
vector is going to be the negative of
the direction of the position vector so
if our position vector is going outward
our acceleration vector our acceleration
vector which i'll draw in green is going
to be going inward the acceleration
vector is going to be inward so it's it
is what we wanted to see and let's see
if we can express this as a function of
the magnitudes so this will also say
that the magnitude of the acceleration
vector and i'll just that's just a
without a
arrow on top i could put brackets around
it is equal to
the negative angular velocity squared
times the magnitude of the position
vector
and what's the magnitude of this
position vector how long is it well its
magnitude is r
right by definition not in the beginning
of the thing so this is just r
so acceleration is equal to the
negative angular velocity squared times
r
and what's angular velocity well we
learned in that video that that angular
velocity i'll do it right here is equal
to v over r if we just talk about the
magnitudes not the vectors remember if
we're not drawing an arrow on top of
these variables they're just scalar
quantities so the acceleration is equal
to
is equal to
and actually we can well we can get rid
of the negative sign because we're just
we're not worried about direction right
now but let's we could keep it there
well it doesn't matter so we get
so what do we get we get v squared
because you know the magnitude of this
absolute value is essentially magnitude
so you get v squared over r squared
times r
so r times r squared you get the
acceleration is v squared over r and
that's what we set out to prove and i'm
out of time now so i'll see you in the
next video hopefully i didn't confuse
you